okay so his energy i take to the back
mid foot
okay so he's pushing and he's just
grounding me
i don't need to brace for anything okay
so as i have a long
relationship to the ground on the back
foot
i have a yin relationship to the ground
on the front foot
so it is in the ikea adhesion
and this is in the cochlea projection
okay
and then i'm going to change the
relationship i'm going to shift the
ground vector
onto the front foot and now this has an
ik
relationship and this has a coherent
projection
so more
don't tense up look you see and then
you're going to push
him out that's not it he's just
energy i'm not fighting him i'm not
doing a wrist scrub technique he's just
weight mass energy
one vector other vector
one yong yin relationship other yin yang
relationship
there's no flexion up top of my body
i'm not flicking my wrist
the body's not doing anything on top
okay let's try it okay so his energy is
coming in and it goes onto that
foot i keep the same feeling i keep the
same
feeling i don't want to try to take
energy off do you see
the same energy i move the energy to the
foot
for the other foot so again same energy
be careful and you go like this is too
heavy and you try to take
energy off well then energy is going to
leak out that way
so right into where he is
right i'm making a quicker
transition
it's a small shift small
shift okay try it okay so now
really small really small
it's the same process
but you're taking out more of the
external okay
so it's really really small barely any
movement
barely any movement
don't go over his mask right into him
he's pushing i'm on the ground vector
nothing's going to knock me down
so i can move i'm going to let off
enough of it to create
a push and here again the sand is
helping the sand is helping i'm on the
ground vector
i'm going to take my front stance and
shift my weight
doing the doing that second the drill
where i push the shift my weight i'm not
doing it a little bit more in movement
and trading sides
pushing pushing is pushing
always pushing
[Music]
when i make contact it's through his
whole body so don't go around his energy
feel his energy shift it onto the back
foot
he's pushing right he's pushing pushing
pushing pushing pushing pushing
go off i let go of him you're going to
see what he's doing
so pushing pushing pushing
[Music]
okay let's try